I met this girl okay and this girl was
telling me her lifting numbers and I
couldn't believe it so I'm six foot this
girl is like 5 six okay and she told me
she could lift 350 lb deadlift now me
the highest I ever got okay I always say
300 it was 285 it was 285 but I round up
I round up okay anyways but that was
without like a belt or anything and she
told me 350 and I'm like how did this
chick she's like half my size your
weight's like important or whatever how
did she get 350 well I found out it was
drugs and this happened to me so much
okay I these chicks will like pick at me
or whatever and I'm like well how do
these women have zero wrinkles how do
they have these like tiny waist guys
they cheat oh my gosh it's so funny they
all take these like drugs um you can
take like pills to be thin I I didn't
understand it for the longest time cuz
I'm like how do these women just get
these like perfect bodies out of nowhere
drugs